[MUSIC PLAYING]
NARRATOR: MIT was founded just
a few years before Canada,
just a few miles from the
birthplace of the American
Revolution.
And that revolutionary spirit
still haunts this place.
From the transistor radio
to computer networks to
pharmaceuticals the stuff that
gets dreamed up, built, and
tested here affects millions.
But MIT's geniuses all have
to somewhere, as freshmen.
Freshmen like--
Every January, the chemistry
department runs a four-week
lab class for freshmen.
The class is called 5.301,
and it teaches practical
techniques that chemists
use every day.
DR. JOHN DOLHUN:
Recrystallization to
distillation to column
chromatography, protein
assays, and it ends with a
research project, where the
students actually synthesize a
penicillin derivative and test
it on live bacteria.
NARRATOR: And those who
pass get a UROP.
ANU: A UROP stands for
undergraduate research
opportunities program, and
it lets you do real
research in a lab.
KATHERINE: It's a great
opportunity for people to get
experience in a lab, figure out
if research is right for
them, and get publications
on your resume.
NARRATOR: This year, 5.301
has 14 students.
Let's meet a few of them.
ANTHONY: My family basically
consists of my mother and my
sister and now my nephew.
ANTHONY'S NEPHEW: M, I, T.
ANTHONY: Yay!
I'm the first, actually, in my
family to go to college.
My mom is the best person
in the world.
When I go home at night and call
her and tell her what I
did in lab, she's always like,
oh, that's interesting.
I think I saw that
in CSI one day.
I'm in the logs.
We run around like crazy men
on Valentine's Day and
interrupt classes and
sing to people.
I'm either Course 5 or Course
10-- for non-MIT, either
chemistry or chemical
engineering.
If I enjoy being in lab, then
Course 5 is probably a really
good choice.
EMILY: If you want to, you could
definitely just lock
yourself in your room and
study all the time.
I just wanted to show
you guys my room.
Here I have a bunch of formulas
for derivatives,
integration by parts, common
polyatomic ions, your basic
kinematic equations
for physics.
So it's kind of up to you
if you want to go
out there and explore.
In high school, I was on the
varsity tennis team, so I
definitely try to do
a lot of that here.
I'm taking a taekwondo class,
which should be interesting.
I'm thinking Course 5, which
is chemistry, or Course 10,
which is chemical engineering.
ETHAN: I do love science, but I
also have that soft spot for
Robert Frost and Walt Whitman.
Instead of writing a
valedictorian speech in high
school, I actually just wrote
a poem that they published,
because I guess I do sort of
like poems more than speeches.
But since my parents want me to
come out of college and be
able to get a job, they
decided that I
will be doing sciences.
And I'm completely
cool with that.
I am the student manager for the
basketball team, so I go
to all the practices
and the games.
I feel that's a really
cool way to relax, I
guess, after class.
LINA: I've always been into
the secret tunnels thing.
Now we're down in the tunnels,
the famous MIT tunnels.
I love playing pranks.
I used to play pranks on my
high school teachers.
Well, my chemistry teacher, back
in high school, he was
really known for giving a lot
of lab reports and grading
them pretty harshly.
So I got my entire AP classes to
give me their lab reports.
We took the front covers of all
these lab reports, and we
just wallpapered his entire
wall with them.
I hope that 5.301 will help me
want to do more research.
IKE: Hey.
What's up, what's up?
This is Ike, AKA,
Smooth Scholar.
Ravens fan-- we're going to win
the Superbowl this year.
So watch out.
This is my first time in lab.
Don't feel intimidated, because
you're going to come
across people who have taken
crazy classes in
high school, you know?
And some of you probably have
never even taken calculus
before, like me.
You're still here, right?
You still made it, so
it still counts.
That's it for now.
NARRATOR: Everyone's excited
to get started.
YI-SHIUAN: I haven't had that
much lab experience.
HANSOL: I haven't worked in a
music lab-- just high school.
JULIE: I haven't done any
research yet in a lab.
JASON: I'm actually
pretty excited.
LEALIA: I'm excited.
DAN: I'm really excited.
YI-SHIUAN: Definitely excited.
JULIE: Really eager to get into
the lab and get hands on
right away.
DAN: I can't wait
to get started.
NARRATOR: But they have no
idea what they're in for.
[MUSIC PLAYING]